now there was a Pharisee named Nicodemus
a leader of the Jews he came to Jesus by
night and said to him rabbi we know that
you are a teacher who has come from God
for no one can do these signs that you
do apart from the presence of God jesus
answered him very truly I tell you no
one can see the kingdom of God without
being born from above Nicodemus said to
him how can anyone be more be born after
having grown old can one enter a second
time into the mother's womb and be born
jesus answered very truly I tell you no
one can enter the kingdom of God without
being born of water and spirit what is
born of the flesh is flesh you must be
born from above the wind blows where it
chooses and you hear the sound of it but
you do not know where it comes from or
where it goes so it is with everyone who
is born of the Spirit
Nicodemus said to him how can these
things be jesus answered him are you a
teacher of Israel and yet you do not
understand these things very truly I
tell you we speak of what we know and
testify to what we have seen yet you do
not receive our testimony if I have told
you about earthly things and you do not
believe how can you believe if I tell
you about heavenly things no one has
ascended into heaven except the one who
descended from heaven the Son of Man and
just as Moses lifted up the serpent in
the wilderness so must the Son of Man be
lifted up
that whoever believes in Him may have
eternal life for God so loved the world
that He gave His only Son so that
everyone believes in him may not perish
but may have eternal life indeed God did
not send the Son into the world to
condemn the world but in order that the
world might be saved through him those
who believed in him are not condemned
but those who do not believe are
condemned already because they have not
believed in the name of the only Son of
God and this is the judgment that the
light has come into the world and people
love darkness rather than light because
their deeds were evil for all who do
evil hate the light and do not come to
the light so that their deeds may not be
exposed but those who do what is true
come to the light so that it may be
clearly seen that their deeds have been
done in God part of the fun of our
conversations through the years is that
I read text through Baptist eyes and you
read them through Roman Catholic eyes
and no matter how often we try to
pretend we simply do it neutrally that
history enters into our readings and as
a Baptist boy growing up especially
everybody's favorite verse in Sunday
school and the kind of grounds on which
we often tried to live our life was that
famous word of Jesus to Nicodemus which
we always translated as you must be born
again when I read the translations I
discover first of all that it takes
place in a context it's not just a
bumper sticker or of kind of poster on
the road as you drive down but that it's
part of a narrative and the narrative is
important in terms of giving it meaning
and I realize that it means more than
one thing that it's one of those puns so
that sometimes the translator says you
must be born again sometimes you must be
born from above
sometimes Nicodemus understands it one
way in Jesus another and help us think
through that phrase in this kind
text mm-hmm well that we begin
confessional II as you did if you grew
up Baptist hearing about being born
again I did grew up Catholic and when we
heard this per could be read in in
church the emphasis was always on what
and the spirit yeah so the insistence on
the sacramental that was a necessary
condition of being born again or being
reborn however we want to understand it
you're absolutely right that one of the
things that's going on here is this pun
the Greek word on oath an can mean again
or it can mean from above and as you
suggested in one of our earlier
conversations John probably intends both
through he intends some sort of rebirth
but not in the way that Nicodemus
understands it and his where the
dramatic irony comes in Nicodemus here's
Jesus speaking on a physical material
level he's obviously speaking on another
lap right right but what is that level
yeah and that's one of the the
intriguing little mysteries that the
reader or listener of this story is is
invited to ponder because it's not a
simple straightforward thing I don't
think that the text is affirming that by
a kind of ritualistic act of pouring
water on someone or dipping someone into
water or saying I believe in Jesus or
another another that's the balance right
that's right yeah so there are ways of
misconstrue yes in both of our general
Christian traditions I guess one of the
the places that I'm drawn to in this
text is the next stage of Jesus's
presentation when he talks about the son
of man being lifted up first of all he
affirms that it's the son of man that's
going to give you the key to this to
being spiritually reborn or born again
and so what does that spiritual rebirth
entail and in another conversation used
the term Midrash to talk about one of
the things that goes on in John and I
think that's right to what it's worth
thinking about what that is coming out
of Jewish tradition Midrash is basically
the interpretation or or delving into
scripture to
new meaning in it and one of the ways in
which Scripture was regularly explored
by Jewish exegesis was to find things
that could be juxtaposed in it to lend
new meaning to one or another of the
texts and the rabbi's had a very
technical way of doing that if there was
a single word that appeared in two
different texts they could link those
texts right they call that guess a Rasha
Wow you don't know I think John is a
little more flexible we'll see him using
some other midrashic techniques but
there is a midrashic technique that pops
up here and I think it points to what
John really wants to do with this theme
of rebirth it has to do what they at the
son of man mm-hmm
and John says in John 3:14 just as Moses
lifted up the serpent in the desert so
it is necessary for the son of man to be
lifted up oh there's so much going on in
that dad that little verse the lifting
up yeah that's a thing see right again
and again a theme of glorification which
we talked about in the prologue and it's
going to lead us through today the
crucifixion and resurrection that's
important because this son of man sang
is pointing ahead pointing ahead to they
the crucifixion it functions that is in
the same way as some Son of Man sayings
do and the Sonata concepts especially in
mark at the end of Margate and of Mark 9
middle mark 10 there we have these son
of man sayings Jesus came to suffer yeah
and this is one of those so it's about
here interesting me the suffering is
clearly already on the way to
glorification that's not so clear in
mark I think that's right that's right
yeah but juxtaposed to that notion of
the suffering son of man is as Moses
lifted up the serpent in the desert so
you have something out of Christian
tradition an affirmation of the
importance of the suffering of the Son
of man which by the way of Oaks Daniel
well in any case it's a Christian
affirmation put side by side with the
notion of the serpent being lifted up on
the pole by seeing which the people of
Israel were healed
so does this begin to sort of reinforce
your Baptist reading of being born again
by just seeing
casually affirming the deity of Jesus or
the revelatory character of Jesus I you
then saved no I don't think so because
seeing in John is one of these loaded
right and you have to see with the eyes
of faith yeah you have to see Jesus
hanging on the cross with those eyes of
faith and then if you do you get it then
you get it then you are spiritually
reborn and I think that's gets back to
what we were talking about earlier about
revelation in John how does revelation
take place and this points toward it you
know that and we'll be exploring this
I'm sure in many ways before we're
through our conversations but it gets to
it through this this image of sight and
that's so very important in in the Greek
tradition for understanding how
revelation takes place you see things
you have a mystery experience in Apothic
they called it a visionary experience of
the truth and I think John is Avoca gnat
in this little text but doing so look
through a Jewish Midrash a fascinating
combination I want to come back to the
believing thing I want a circle back to
the pun for a minute and it's the born
again born from above and I think
clearly born again is not either just
being baptized or either just walking
down at the altar call in a Baptist
Church and saying I love Jesus I've been
convinced and I'd love to try this out
on you by Lou Martin one of our friends
and colleagues that part of what's going
on here is a struggle between the
synagogue and the church and that what
you has some of our exemplary figures
and Nicodemus here the band born blind
in John 9 our examples to Jewish
synagogue members encouraging them to be
able to move out and take on the risks
of becoming part of a messianic
Christian movement of confessing Jesus
and because I have used you as my
Nicodemus example through the years I'm
not gonna do it in your presence this is
the Dean of Yale Divinity this is what
happens when Nicodemus who's a leader
not just a member of the congregation
he's the leader of the congregation
begins to suspect there's something in
the Jesus story and what he risks by
that faith is not being born again some
simple spiritual sense though that it
not in some simple-minded spiritual
sense but in a deeply spirit
since which will threaten all his being
and the way I use you as an example in
this is the DNA VL Divinity School
secretly is impressed by the Mormons
around the corner and one day he sneaks
in to talk the Mormon leader and is
convinced that in fact in addition to
all the scriptures you and I have loved
all our lives there's this other thing
the Book of Mormon which points beyond
doesn't contradict necessarily our
relation but points beyond it how do you
then come to the faculty and say sisters
and brothers in Christ and Moroni I have
now decided to become a Mormon
you'd be born again you'd lose your job
you'd lose your status
we'll talk about your marriage later
during coffee hour this would not be
good news and I think I think the
born-again thing partly is all right if
you're going to take this thing on it
takes risk and one of them that drives
me nuts with my Baptist sisters and
brothers sometimes is the thing that
born-again is all a matter of what you
do with your intellect and your and your
heart and not what you do with your body
and sometimes being born again means are
we orient my life giving up some of the
things I've cherished most I think
that's the along with the other I think
that's part of the pressure of this
story mm-hmm yeah I think you're right
and we're going to going to be seeing a
number of points throughout the gospel
where there are hooks on to social
realities exactly and exactly how those
social realities have brought in and
what kind of comment the Evangelist is
making on them we can debate but that
they it's certainly important to
emphasize that we have in Nicodemus a
representative of the leading stratum of
Jewish society leading intellectually
leading spiritually and standing for
certain certain kinds of things and for
the importance of of purity in in Israel
for extension of the sanctity of the
temple to wall of Israel right these are
things that that lurk in the background
if you say Pharisee very much and he
would be giving that up by a Mason he
wasn't wanting was a big deal who was
crucified there's a similar dynamic in
Paul in Galatians 3 again we come back
Joe parallels at least between Paul and
John and in Paul in Galatians he talks
about at the passage in Deuteronomy
where curse' does he was hung on a tree
and what he's saying is in fact well
he's saying that that curse is
eliminated from us by Jesus accepting it
there's a notion of a Toman but the
curse is there and the curse is what you
embrace if you embrace Jesus Hebrews
does the same thing absolutely so it's
it's certainly an element in in the
social world out of which this text
comes well that brings us back again to
what you were saying about the what what
is let's do the what is the morning
what's the board from a both part I
think in a way we get the born-again
peace
what's the born from above and how does
that relate to the lifting up and I do
think it's a matter of faith which sees
but does more than see that it because
what's obvious is a serpent on a stick
or a crucified guy on a cross what's
less obvious is the healing power of the
Lord God or the redemptive power of the
word in Jesus and that takes more than
sight it takes some deeper commitment
exactly it takes deeper insight deeper
insight because the notion of being born
from above and thereby don't born again
is something that floats around in the
general environment of the gospel you
find some notions to that effect in some
greco-roman piety in places like the
Hermetic tradition which talked about a
spiritual rebirth you have it also in
Philo and in both of them spiritual
rebirth has something to do with
embracing a life of virtue Philo being
that first century the first century
Jewish philosopher minor that's right
two worlds who combined greco-roman
philosophy and Jewish biblical
interpretation and in both of those
sources and sort of greco-roman popular
religion of one particular stripe and in
this Jewish appropriation of that whole
tradition you have the notion of a
second birth of the human being when
they come to spiritual and moral
adulthood and embrace a life of virtue
and so that's probably lurking in the
background this is another case where
John takes a notion plays with it and
pushes it even further because how do
you get to that level of moral
maturation or embracing
some sort of spiritual principle he says
you do it through the cross yeah how
does that how is that going to happen
you know is one of the things now
another interesting thing is that Philo
connects his notions of spiritual
rebirth with language of the Spirit and
coming to someone and being infused in
someone by reading scripture inspire
understanding the Pentateuch by
understanding the Torah I think one of
the things that John is doing is saying
in our tradition o you representatives
of the synagogue you can get there but
you don't get there by reading Torah you
get there by reading Jesus yeah
absolutely I mean Jesus Jesus is that
place where God reveals God's full will
for humankind as the synagogue believed
happened in Torah mm-hmm now we have
grace in addition to grace or instead of
grace this even fuller thing which is
word incarnate let's go back to the to
the born again of water and the spirit I
think the Catholics weren't dead wrong
about that looks like it baptism is
involved there somehow oh how do you do
how do you go with that one yeah in two
ways well first of all thinking a little
bit about the sacraments in in John it's
long with a controversy in johanan
scholarship whether there's a kind of
layer of writing of in the text that
represents a kind of secondary addition
that brings in some ecclesiastical
concerns that weren't part of the
original evangelists vision I don't buy
that I see a coherent whole here that
works in in internal stages but not in
different writing tutorial stages and I
do see that John is very much interested
in the ways in which Christians sort of
celebrate and structure their lives and
he sees this in some ways as analogous
to and inspired by the ways in which the
Jewish tradition structured the life of
Israel one of the ways in which the
first dozen chapters of the gospel is
structured is by recalling Jewish feasts
reminiscing a similar putting the acts
of Jesus in a similar sequence and with
each of these feasts there's something
symbolic or if you will sacramental and
we'll be talking a little bit more
about that a little later on when we
come to the bread of life discourse or
in connection with the man born blind
there's a tie in absolutely tabernac so
their time into the Jewish festival
cycle and to Jewish symbolic instruments
we can call them sacraments if you will
sure and certainly one of the the key
things that all earlier just about all
the early Christians that we know of did
was to baptize they had somewhat
different understandings of what they
were up to but it's there and I think
John is saying yes it's water in the
spirit that makes for this new birth but
you have to understand it right in the
same way as when it comes to talk about
the Eucharist yes
it's sharing the bread and the the wine
the body and the blood of Christ but you
have to understand it right or have to
see it you have to get it and in order
to see it and get it you have to read
the whole of his gospel yeah absolutely
yes so that's one strand there is a
sacramental layer in John there's also
the symbolism of water and water is
going to be popping up in all sorts of
interesting places it popped up in a
section that we haven't talked about the
miracle at Cana yeah where water gets
transformed into wine and the water is
the water from the purification
purification rites of the Jews another
theme and then it's going to be popping
up again in the next episode that we're
going to be talking about a woman if
they the well so we'll save that and
then it comes up again in chapter 7
where Jesus has a mysterious phrase
about water bubbling up in the belly
mmm whose bellies belly or the believers
very empty very unclear and then at the
very end you have water and blood coming
from the side of the crucified Jesus at
the moment when it is consummated you
know it's all put together when the
glorification takes place and the
revelation has been done it's there and
then you have first John picking up on
the theme and insisting that it's both
water and blood right that's involved
and I think that's important yeah that
is all early Christians are doing
something with water right it's a ritual
act a ritual act of initiation into this
this communion John is saying yes you
have to have that as the condition of
rebirth but you have to have it with the
blood that is you have to have it with
his own
what Jesus does of the significance of
Jesus death yes some of my students last
week we're looking at this text in class
suggested and I've not seen this before
I think it's not bad that in some ways
born again of water and the spirit takes
the two sides of the enouth and pun born
again of water is the baptism in the
community born again of the Spirit
guarantees that that's not just a human
decision but that it comes from above so
that in an interesting way Jesus Sean
unpacks his own pun when Jesus says here
the two things you've got to do just as
my word born again and born from above
means two things so the the way one
becomes a faithful person involves two
inseparable moves mm-hmm I kind of like
that
and I like that too um it leads into one
other dimension of the text that we've
read here and that's the final comment
on judgment yeah because there's John
said good news is a two-edged sword
there's good news all along for those
who see and accept and understand who
this Jesus is and what the revelation is
that comes through his death and
resurrection but there's also judgment
on those who don't
yeah and it's a curious theme because it
in many places and the gospel will say
Jesus did not come to judge but at the
same time judgment happens absolutely
judgment happens when you fail to get it
and they the articulation of the theme
here is interesting because it's so much
connected with works yes that's that's
puzzling to a deeply Protestant
Protestant how did that ever get in
there how have we slipped that past that
was the cleese yeah I think for John as
for Paul living a life of love and
action is what faith is all about so you
can't separate the kids right Luther to
the contrary exactly what standing on
his bad days mm-hmm the other thing
about the judgment which which will see
again time and time again is that
there's a way in which an early
Christian tradition certainly was
judgment will come John time after time
says judgment has come this is judgment
not this will be the judgment the
judgment is that the light shines and we
refuse to live in the light so you don't
have to wait for the last day come on to
see whether you're in darkness if you're
in darkness you're in darkness and baby
that's all the judgment you need
that's right yeah this ties in with a
larger concern of John about time he
does funny things with time and we'll
see that when we come to the last supper
discourses I don't know if we'll be able
to go into all of the details the epic
John seems to collapse time yeah it
comes out in connection with the son of
man language because one of the ways in
which Christians early Christians talked
about the Son of Man was as the coming
judge actually the one who was going to
be coming with that on the clouds of
heaven with his angels around him and
his Matthew put Centrino will separate
the sheep goats as an entire yeah yeah
that all seems to happen in John in the
air now so the son of man who's hung
there on the tree is the son of man who
exercises judgment not by doing any
judgment himself but by eliciting a
decision our friend that you mentioned
in our earlier conversation Rudolph wolf
by the great theologian of the 20th
century insisted on that as one of the
main points of the gospel that is in his
whole New Testament theology the call to
judgment the call to decision is what
the Christian character is all about it
and there is that element here as well
and also I want to push you on what
might a little better push us both on
moving on for him in a way that that
happened new every morning mm-hmm day
was judgment day you decided for Jesus
or against Jesus and in some ways it was
very much like the Baptist pious now I'm
going to decide but I don't think there
was a kind of a once saved always safer
and we called it the dualism of decision
and in some ways each day I have to
decide where I am and that is that John
or is that built mom reading
existentialism and delighting to find it
in John I think it's more the latter
than the former but but this is this way
in which John plays with time could open
it to the notion that there's a decision
every day I think for John going back to
the social dimension that you were
talking about at the beginning of our
conversation today there is a one time
moment when a very important judgment is
going to be made but then John is also
concerned and this comes out even more
on the Johannine epistles with the
ongoing life of the community and so
there's a tension there between the the
moment of separation the moment of
determination of community identity and
then what happens to the believer once
they're inside yeah you don't want them
to fall away no
why does this why does Nicodemus
disappear from this story
oh wise leader there they are having
this conversation and then it's all over
and somebody's talking away well about
God so loved the world and we're not
sure that's Jesus or the narrator and
Nicodemus doesn't say a mumbling word
because he's no longer there as far as
we can tell right there are some
interesting moves that John makes as a
narrator or that we find a little
strange but in some ways some of the
most interesting work done on John as a
piece of literature lately has called
call to our attention some parallels
between what goes on in this text and
ancient Greek drama yes one of my
beloved students at Yale and some of the
I bet I haven't seen an example of this
but I bet we could find some some close
parallels to a scene that sort of trails
off where the chorus comes in and starts
giving you convicts it up from there
where the protagonist sort of stands
silent over on the side of the stage
that's the way I envision what goes on
here in the Nicodemus episode because a
lot of the themes that have picked up
toward the end of the chapter have
already been articulated in the
conversation between Jesus and the
cadena certainly but it's another voice
coming in at that point one of the
things I have to remind my students is
that we don't have punctuation and we
don't even have word separation in the
earliest manuscripts so if there's no
way of telling from any early quotation
marks where Jesus stops talking and the
narrator comes in and one of the puzzles
not much hangs on it but it always
interests me does Jesus say for God so
loved the world that He gave the only
Son or as the narrator now coming in
Jesus gone to one side Nicodemus to the
other and says here's what all this
means
what does 3:16 mean we shouldn't leave
this passage with a Roman gothic
reflection on the Baptist's other
favorite passage John 3:16 the stadium
theologist stadium theology the bumper
sticker word right one of the things
that intrigues me here is the insistence
on the way in which God loves the world
yeah this after this moment of intense
separation between those who accept and
those who don't and this is another
tension that runs through the whole of
the gospel is and it goes back to what
we were talking about in the prologue
there's a universalistic impulse that
said God is in relationship with the
whole of the world from the beginning it
relates to it's now and ever
a particular way and I think we have I
think it's huge I think that caught that
contractors use karl barth thinks that
he got the premise right in the
conclusion wrong that if God so loves
the world then it shouldn't just be
those who are explicitly believers but
somehow the whole world needs to be
redeemed but that's an extra biblical
theological I thought that impulse goes
back to origins and goes back to origin
and over to others in there in our time